She didn't fall in love with you because you
remembered her birthday and bought her flowers
on Valentine's Day.
She fell in love with you because when you
woke up in the morning you said, "good morning"'
to her before you checked your phone.
She fell in love with you because when you
went to the fridge to get yourself a drink,
you got her one without even asking.
She fell in love with you because when you
had an amazing day at work and she came home
and she had a terrible day at work, you didn't
say "yeah, yeah, yeah but let me tell you
about my day."
You sat and listened to her awful day and
you didn't say a thing about
your amazing day.
This is why she fell in love with you.
I can't tell you exactly what day and it was
no particular thing you did.
It was the accumulation of all of
those little things,
that she woke up one days and as if
she pressed a button she goes, "I love him."
And the same with the relationship, it's not
about the events.
It's not about intensity, it's about consistency.